[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette édition spéciale sur tv fil 78
nous allons faire ensemble le point sur
les résultats du second tour de
l'élection législative dans les yvelines
onze députés sur 12 possibles dans le
département la république en marche a
presque réussi un grand chelem
réaction de ces nouveaux élus à suivre
certains ont fait leurs premiers pas
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
large victoire pour le parti
présidentiel mais aussi record
d'abstention c'est l'autre enseignement
de ce scrutin et les yvelines ne font
pas de l'exception
et puis nous nous poserons à la question
de l'avenir des autres formations
politiques et des républicains en
socialistes tous s'accordent sur la
nécessaire clarification des idées et la
reconstruction amorcée au plus vite et
pour être débutés à voici a le visage
les visages des nouveaux élus dans le
sud du département six nouveaux députés
élus plus ou moins largement de didier
baichère dans la première
circonscription à florence grand jury
dans la 12e
aucun d'entre eux n'a siégé auparavant
une partie n'a même jamais exercé de
mandat c'était donc une grande
découverte pour eux ce matin et que de
se retrouver à l'assemblée nationale
comme pour béatrice piron député de la
3e circonscription
vous la voyez sur ces images issues de
son compte twitter autre élu des
yvelines présente ce lundi au palais
bourbon aurore bergé elle en revanche
est loin d'être une novice en politique
en marge de son mandat de conseillère
municipale d'opposition à magny les
hameaux
elle était en charge d'une partie de la
campagne d'alain juppé pendant la
primaire de la droite
au programme de son premier déplacement
découverte des lieux ou encore remise
d'une mallette spéciale avec à
l'intérieur par exemple le règlement
intérieur de l'assemblée nationale une
visite marquée aussi forcément par les
émotions beaucoup d'émotion
évidemment et et je pense qu'il faut
vraiment pas oublier pourquoi on a été
c'est ça qui est essentielle
c'est que ces lieux déjà on y est à
peine locataires on est de passage
il faut bien l'avoir en tête je pense et
puis pour pas oublier pourquoi on est là
et quelle mission doit remplir en y
étant on est là pour travailler
moi j'ai demandé à siéger au sein de la
commission culture et éducation et puis
en faisant un vrai travail de proximité
moi c'est ce que j'ai ressenti en cette
campagne
ça a beaucoup manqué de démocratie
locale en tout cas c'est ça qu'on nous a
souvent dit donc évidemment il va
falloir être extrêmement présents sur le
terrain et l'installation des députés va
se poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine du côté des réactions à présent
à cette élection législative écouter
tout d'abord aziz françois n'diaye
présent hier lors de notre soirée
électorale sur tv fils responsable en
marche dans les yvelines il se dit
soulagé un an à peu près après le début
de cette aventure politique tous
soulagés que les choses se passent bien
parce que il ya quelques semaines
quelques - qui l'eût cru donc soulagé
que les français nous y fit confiance
malgré ce taux d'abstention assez élevé
je pense que c'est aussi la confirmation
que le projet que nous portons le projet
que nous avons construit avec les
français est un projet qui finalement
rassure les français et veulent qu'ils
veulent le voir au moins essayé pour les
cinq ans qui viennent
et s'il est une formation qui profitent
de cet élan en marche c'est bien à son
allié le modem le président du modem
dans les yvelines
elle s'impose d'ailleurs dans la 9e
circonscription écoutez le au micro de
haussmann band ardennes je pense qu'on a
fait une très très bonne campagne et je
veux surtout féliciter les marcheuses et
marcheurs parce qu'ils ont été des
neiges incroyable c'était une véritable
armée ils ont été partout moi aussi
d'ailleurs mais ils ont été partout
aussi en soutien ça a été quelque chose
de fantastique alors sur la
circonscription même on va commencer moi
je vais commencer par aller voir les
nerfs bien évidemment il va faire et
j'avais discuté avec eux et on va
commencer par mettre en place notre
plateforme collaborative pour faire
remonter les projets à la fois des
citoyens et des maires pour pourvoir
comment comment on met tout ça en oeuvre
et comment je peux les unes les autres
formations politiques il jouait aussi
gros dans ce scrutin quel avenir pour
elle la france insoumise et le front
national n'ont pas maintenu deux
candidats dans le département des
yvelines
mais ces formations séjour ont bien les
biens dans l'hémicycle l'élection de
monsieur macron a balayé en fait tout
l'échiquier politique est telle qu'on
connaissait depuis 35 à 40 ans je crois
qu on vient on arrive justement à
l'apogée de ce que
nous ne nous appelions
voilà pour résumer tout ça l'ump est ce
parce qu'on va dire vrai ils prennent
ils prennent cher républicain et
prennent parti socialiste et au pire
mélange tout ça et ça s'appelle en
marche
donc la vraie question maintenant c'est
quelle place pour les patriotes et les
souverainistes et je pense que là on a
un vrai rôle à jouer et a aussi un vrai
rôle
je vous êtes à l'heure des veilleurs
public mais aussi donner un écho à tout
ce peuple qui s'est abstenu et donc qui
est sorti du corps politique français je
voudrais terminer sur une note positive
si vous me permettez c'est qu'il ya
d'énormes choses à reconstruire que nous
on espère avoir posé les bases avec un
mouvement hors parti très jeune ouvert
et puis un travail à faire d'eux de
résistance contre les ordonnances macro
et j'encourage vraiment tout le monde
tous ceux qui m'écoutent à rejoindre
massivement les syndicats formation qui
sort la plus d'estimé de cette élection
le parti socialiste dans les yvelines
l'ancien parti au pouvoir perd ses deux
sièges de député sandrine grand gambe la
responsable départementale du parti
socialiste soutient de benoît hamon
évoque justement cette recomposition à
venir c'était aussi hier soir sur notre
plateau nous on est clairement dans une
période là il faut refonder refonder la
gauche c'est d'ailleurs ce que benoît
hamon a commencé à dire et qui va faire
dès le 1er juillet mais
bon on était un certain nombre depuis
2014 suite à la vague qui vous apportez
vous comme nouveau maire mais on était
incertain en avoir dit là il s'est passé
quelque chose donc été aussi une
première
un premier message qu'avait été envoyé
suite aux deux ans de preuve deux
premières années du quinquennat on n'a
pas été entendu je pense que voilà la
politique qui a été menée n'était pas
assez clair n était pas identifier
clairement par les gens comme étant ning
politiques de gauche ring politique de
centre gauche ou de droite
résultat d'un désaveu généralisée et une
confusion au sein de la gauche qui est
qui explique aussi la situation que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant et c'est à
nous aussi de deux de travail et de
repos frire du côté des élus locaux
toujours se pose aussi à présent la
question du travail avec ces nouveaux
députés novices pour la plupart écouter
michel logis et président de saint
quentin en yvelines
je ne fais jamais de jugement de valeur
avant je le fais après lorsque sonné
dans de la pratique c'est pour ça que
j'attends là aussi le nouveau président
lorsque enfin il va présider le nouveau
gouvernement quant au fun il va
gouverner de voir exactement quelles
sont les mesures qui seront prises
aujourd'hui nous sommes que dans des
promesses dont des photos de magazines
mais on n'est pas encore dans le travail
effectif donc attendons et juges ont en
tout cas on a besoin de parlementaires
on a besoin de parlementaires qui n'ont
pas soit présent sur le terrain mais qui
comprennent le terrain c'est tout à fait
différent dont moi j'ai besoin de points
de parlementaires qui comprennent le
terrain et c'est vrai que
ceux qui aujourd'hui font nous
représenter pour une grande partie ont
aucune expérience locale
enfin à noter les réactions de pierre
bédier président des yvelines de valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région de
l'île de france tout de républicains
pour le premier la france a changé la
société a changé seuls les partis
politiques sont restés figés sur des
idéologies et des pratiques dépassé et
puis pour la seconde elle estimé désir
soir que la droite avait raté son
rendez-vous avec les français lors des
élections législatives
elle appelle à reconstruire la droite et
le centre
l'autre enseignement de ce scrutin c'est
la très forte abstention et vous voyez
ces chiffres pour le département mais
aussi au niveau national ce sont des
records depuis 1958 et il conviendrait
aussi de noter que cette forte hausse de
l'abstention se double d'un bond
spectaculaire du nombre de bulletins
blancs et deux bulletins nuls comment
expliquer cette situation écouter à deux
analyses de politologues tout d'abord
stéphane samson de l'université de
versailles saint quentin puis deux
céline braconnier de sciences po à saint
germain on pouvait pas espérer autre
chose
pour deux raisons d'abord pour une
raison très structurelle selon laquelle
la participation au second tour est en
principe inférieure à celle du premier
tour de manière générale pour tous les
scrutins et spécifiquement pour les
législatives et puis une seconde raison
une raison un peu plus un peu plus
conjoncturelle au titre de laquelle il
ya un phénomène
on l'a déjà dit dimanche dernier un
phénomène de lassitude est aussi liée à
la place qu'il ait fait au parlement
dans notre vie politique qui le rend
très peu visible pour le simple citoyen
qui n'est pas passionné par la politique
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de citoyens
qui savent pas trop à quoi servent les
députés et sim le savent
ah c'est d'une part parce qu'on a on a
un problème d'éducation
et puis il ya évidemment qui a un effet
plus conjoncturel pour expliquer le la
très forte hausse de l'abstention cette
année qui est l' annonce des résultats
avant même que l'élection ait lieu et
dans les yvelines on notera que la plus
forte abstention se trouve dans la 8e
circonscription avec plus de 63 % des
inscrits qui ne se sont pas déplacés
dans la 11e également
58,31 % des électeurs ont aussi boudé
les urnes la 11e qui comporte lé ville
de trappes et de la verrière nous allons
revenir à présent dans la suite de cette
édition spéciale sur les résultats dans
les différentes circonscriptions et tout
d'abord dans la première circonscription
résultat le plus serré le match opposait
didier baichère à françois-xavier
bellamy sujet michael almy d'euros
douche froide pour les républicains dans
la première circonscription des yvelines
à droite depuis 1963 le bastion a cédé
sous la vague de la république en marche
françois-xavier bellamy n'a pas réussi à
inverser la tendance du premier tour où
il avait réalisé seulement 27 49 % des
suffrages contre 42 points 15 % pour le
candidat de la république en marche
didier baichère malgré une belle
remontée l'homme politique de 31 ans
s'inclinent finalement 2 827 voix
j'espérais au soir du premier tour et
j'en étais convaincu que nous pouvions
rattraper le retard pourtant important
qui nous séparait de notre concurrent
dans marche c'était possible et on l'a
prouvé
on a reçu 7000 voix de plus dans l'entré
deux tours mais on s'arrête voilà sur le
seuil de cette victoire parce que je
crois profondément c'est que nous vivons
un phénomène national sur lequel
finalement on avait bien peu de prise il
suffit de constater les autres scores
des yvelines et de voir que là on fait
le l'un des meilleurs scores de toutes
les yvelines aujourd'hui et c'est
vraiment une fierté
la défaite de françois xavier bellamy
est également un coup dur pour le député
dvd sortant françois de mazières
le maire de versailles qui avait
remporté la circonscription en 2012 avec
56% des voix est prêt à travailler a
conseillé le nouveau député
je lui ai proposé tout alors se voir
rapidement ce qui nous semble important
de suivre en tant que parlementaire
c'est évident et il n'y a aucune raison
à partir du moment où les électeurs ont
décidé qu'il était déviée on ne
travaille pas et puis qu'on travaille de
façon plus positive
cette baisse après l'annoncé officielle
dans sa permanence de campagne plage
charreaux à versailles didier béchard
analyse avec ses soutiens les scores
dans les différentes communes
dans le détail le candidat l'emportent
de 27 points à montigny le bretonneux et
de 41 points lyon cour à versailles
c'est françois-xavier bellamy qui
l'emportent ils totalisent plus de 60
29% des suffrages
je pensais pas honnêtement versailles
remonterait au temps par rapport à la
semaine dernière mais d'un autre côté la
semaine dernière c'était vraiment une
surprise d'être au coude à coude sur
versailles donc je pense que j'avais
beaucoup de gens qui n'avaient pas voté
la semaine dernière donc très bien pour
mon concurrent d'avoir remonté pour lui
à versailles comme ça ça partage un peu
la peine avec lui après avoir savouré sa
victoire dans sa permanence didier
pêcheurs se remettra en marche dès ce
mercredi pour ses premiers pas à
l'assemblée nationale et pour poursuivre
cette édition spéciale résultats du
second tour de l'élection législative
dans le département des yvelines camy
lombaire bonsoir nicolas quere lovitz
nous allons revenir sur vos
circonscriptions dans un instant et avec
mélanie poquet également bonsoir à vous
on part pour la deuxième avec vous cette
transcription elle bascule elle aussi
s'était pourtant un territoire détenus
par la droite depuis 1988 alors le
candidat et roem et nouveau député ce
nom
jean-noël barrot un ingénieur chercheur
de 34 ans il est membre du comité
exécutif du modem le parti de françois
bayrou et son mandat encourt conseiller
départemental de haute loire alors son
nom n'est peut-être pas inconnu pour
certains d'entre vous puisque jean noël
barrot est le fils de jacques barrot
ancien ministre de jacques chirac et de
vallées giscard d'estaing et la
députation et de famille gut wilfrid
parce que son grand père a aussi siégé
au palais bourbon
alors il hier soir on l'a vu il a
confirmé son score du premier tour
puisqu'il a été élu avec plus de 58% des
voix
il devait intégrer à la rentrée le
campus hec de jouy-en-josas comme
professeur sa rentrée des classes est
donc retardé de cinq ans et me confier
hier soir vouloir être un député de
terrain avec une permanence mobile sur
le territoire de sa circonscription et
devrait faire ses premiers pas au palais
bourbon dans les jours à venir
il a déjà des idées sur sa participation
au sein de l'assemblée nationale
ma formation et mon métier me
prédisposait à oeuvrer pour l'évaluation
des politiques publiques est un axe fort
du programme que nous avons défendues
donc j'espère pouvoir le faire dans les
commissions auxquelles je pourrai
participer peut-être la commission des
finances où celle des affaires
économiques dans lesquels je pourrais
apporter mon expérience et mes
compétences et face à lui pascal
thévenot au député sortant député de
courte durée à peu près un an il perd
son siège
le maire de vélizy villacoublay a été
député 15 mois seulement il avait
remporté les élections législatives
partielles de mars 2016 après la
démission de valérie pécresse alors élu
à la présidence de la région ile de
france
il dit lui-même que c'était un petit cdd
passionnant mais c'est bien sûr une
grande déception pour le candidat l'est
républicain l'ambiance était plutôt
pesant à l'hôtel de ville surtout au
moment de l'annoncé des résultats une
grosse déception mais pas pour moi moi
c'est pas bien grave mais je pense que
c'est un beau challenge qui a été perdu
une dynamique était perdu pour nos
villes mais
voilà sur les yvelines on va se
débrouiller autrement et puis j'ai
toujours la région qui porte nos projets
au niveau transports et économie et
je pense que ça reste à inventer on
n'était déjà pas beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprises sur
les bancs de l'assemblée nationale là on
parle de société civile c'est beaucoup
de fonctionnaires c'est beaucoup de
profs je vais te remplacer par un prof
bon bah écoutez nous apprendra ce qu'il
faut faire pour créer de la valeur et
monter les entreprises et cette année on
l'a entendu pour pascal thévenot
désavoué aussi dans sa propre commune de
vélizy parce qu'à velizy n'ont pu pascal
thévenot n'arrive pas en tête c'est
jean-noël barrot qui remporte le
suffrage avec 56% des voix
mais ce qui marque surtout sur vélizy
villacoublay et sur toute la
circonscription c'est l'abstention la 2e
circonscription est elle aussi touchée
si au premier tour 41 % des électeurs ne
s'étaient pas déplacés pour le deuxième
tour le chiffre de l'abstention et 2 50%
pourtant les deux candidats ont battu le
pavé dans cette semaine d'entre deux
tours pour aller à la rencontre de ces
abstentionnistes multipliant tractage et
réunions publiques
alors si pascal thévenot a quand même
réduit son retard sur jean noël barrot
ça ne lui a pas suffit pour conserver
son siège de député la syrie de la 2e
circonscription où wilfrid est elle
aussi en marche et un autre symbole de
cette nette victoire de la république
est en marche dans les yvelines c'est
une autre défaite des républicains dans
la troisième circonscription nicolas le
maire du chesnay un autre maire un autre
élu un maire du chesnay cette fois-ci
philippe brillault qui est battu cette
fois ci par une novice en politique
béatrice piron oui c'est l'un des
nouveaux visages de l'assemblée
nationale béatrice pire on s 52 ans
responsable jusqu'à présent d'une agence
de services de maintien à domicile et
qui est donc élu dès sa première
campagne électorale elle totalise sur la
troisième circonscription près de 59%
des voix exprimées la victoire est donc
nette et sans bavure pour la candidate
de la république en marche
victoire d'autant plus surprenante que
ce territoire cette troisième
circonscription est très ancré à droite
oui et pour eux et pour preuve de
l'ampleur du mouvement comme lors du
premier tour même si l'écart s'est
resserré entre les deux candidats
béatrice pire on rafle une nouvelle fois
la ville du chéné là-haut philippe
brillault est élu maire depuis 1989 le
symbole est forcément important au total
la nouvelle députée arrive en tête dans
douze des treize communes de la
circonscription seule la ville de
recours lui résiste entre guillemets
puisque ça se joue entre deux
une seule voix seulement alors comment
expliquer de tels résultats écouter la
réponse de la principale intéressée
réactions recueillies hier soir s'est
basé sur quelques principes je pense
qu'il faut être à l'écouté des gens je
crois qu'ils ont besoin qu'on les écoute
et je crois qu'ils avaient aussi besoin
de renouveau donc je crois que j'incarne
le renouveau et le fait d'avoir été
auprès d'eux depuis plusieurs mois
d'avoir organisé des réunions régulières
a vraiment transformer la vision qu'ils
avaient donc de comment on peut faire de
la politique et c'est ce qui les a
motivés à me suivre
et hier il était du coup un peu plus de
22000 à se pencher sur béatrice piron à
la suivre dans les urnes si on se penche
justement sur le nombre de voix entre
les deux tours la candidate élue rockets
500 voix supplémentaires philippe
brillault lui signe qu'il résiste quand
même gagne à près de 4000 voix entre le
premier et le second tour mais
évidemment vous le savez ça reste
insuffisant pour devenir député
et quel avenir donc pour philippe
brillault maire du chesnay
alors il l'a annoncé hier soir ans aux
tv fil 78 en direct après ce sixième
échec à la députation philippe brillault
ne se représentera plus aux élections
législatives et il analyse et déjà elle
est première raison de sa nouvelle
défaite c'était aussi hier en direct
écouter la problématique et de
bénéficier je lis bien bénéficiant entre
guillemets du la lecture qui ne nous a
pas porté mon service voire plutôt
desservi
et puis de l'autre côté ben je dirais un
mouvement qui a bénéficié et du
ras-le-bol de des autres partis et de
l'autre côté d'un président de la
république qui pour l'instant à faire un
sans faute puisque depuis maintenant 15
jours les actions à l'international et
dans d'autres pays ont été quelque part
le meilleur vecteur de campagne que
pouvaient avoir les villes actives
actuellement avec quelques informations
concernant les deux communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines villepreux et les
clayes-sous-bois béatrice pire on y
arrive large
en tête avec à chaque fois plus de 65 %
des suffrages
à noter quand même que l'abstention a
dépassé les 58% aux clayes-sous-bois
c'est le taux le plus élevé de cette
circonscription et on passe de la 3e à
la 10e circonscription aurore bergé il a
été élu à députés nous en parlions au
début de cette édition spéciale en
obtenant 64% des suffrages lors de ce
second tour elle devance très largement
jean frédéric poisson le député sortant
récit de cette soirée électorale c'est
avec nicolas landry les résultats
définitifs sont tombés sans surprise
aurore bergé est élu député
une victoire fêtée au qg improvisé à
smart cities campus des photos pour
immortaliser cette soirée la république
en marche vient de conquérir la 10e
circonscription ancrée à droite depuis
excepté entre 2010 et 2012 avec la
députation de anny poursinoff
représentante europe ecologie les verts
moi je serai loyal au président de la
république parce que c'est grâce à lui
aussi évidemment que je suis élu ce soir
et je serai libre libre évidemment de
construire et a proposé à innover à
permettre que la loi soit plus efficaces
soient plus justes soient plus lisibles
parce que c'est ça que les gens nous ont
demandé moi ce que j'ai entendu dans
cette campagne c'est des électeurs qui
nous ont dit c'est le mandat de la
dernière chance
on veut bien vous faire confiance cette
fois ci et vous ratez pas dans les
yvelines la république en marche réalise
son meilleur score dans cette
circonscription en obtenant 64% des
suffrages
une satisfaction pour les militants du
territoire ils vont poursuivre leur
marche pour accompagner le travail de
leurs parlementaires comme aurore va
continuer je vais continuer comme ça
continue de marcher on se repose on se
reposera blast l'avait emporté
réunis on va se répéter
on va réfléchir c'est les thèmes pour
lui apporter des réflexions qu'elle
puisse défendre les projets au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale ça représente un
esprit nouveau
ça représente un nouveau souffle surtout
sur une circo qui était quand même un
peu une baronnie ça fait du bien un
esprit vrai quelqu'un jeunes de
constructive de collaboratif un super
esprit quoi autre ambiance du côté de la
salle patenôtre lors de l'annoncé des
résultats définitifs sur rambouillet
jean frédéric poisson recueille près de
38% dans cette commune sur l'ensemble de
la circonscription y gagne 5000 voix par
rapport au premier tour mais c'est
insuffisant pour rattraper son retard
accompagné de ses soutiens le candidat
du parti chrétien démocrate a félicité
son adversaire
il va poursuivre son combat politique
sur rambouillet avec un regard attentif
sur les activités du parlement
je pense que la démocratie que nous
avons connues jusqu'ici avec ses défauts
mais aussi beaucoup de qualités n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec celle qui
s'annonce et elle méritera celle qui
s'annonce toute la vigilance de
personnes comme nous tous comme moi qui
connaissent bien les institutions qui
sont attentives à ce que la liberté à la
fois du parlement et des citoyens soient
respectés
nous verrons comment cela tournera mais
je serai en tout cas vigilant sur tout
ce qui va se passer dans les mois qui
viennent comme au niveau national ce
scrutin reste entachée par une forte
abstention 51% dans la 10e
circonscription
sur quoi ni remords pas ce taux dépasse
même les 50 5%
à noter aussi le niveau élevé de
bulletins blancs et nuls près de 3% des
inscrits la république en marche a
remporté 11 des 12 sièges du département
s est imposé aussi dans la 11e
circonscription face à jean-michel
fourgous le maire républicain
d'elancourt à la candidate république en
marche nadia s impose avec presque 50 3%
des voix elle emporte dans toutes les
communes de cette circonscription sauf à
elancourt ville dont jean michel
fourgous et le maire stéphane servant
véronique de la maison neuve pour ce
sujet il est d'un peu plus de 21 heures
quand jean michel fourgous le candidat
l'est républicain vient annoncer sa
défaite dans la 11e circonscription des
yvelines
sa seule satisfaction être en tête dans
sa ville d'elancourt
c'est vrai que mes shows une petite
déception mais je dirais qu'il ya un tel
tsunami des nationales que écoutez je
suis content de voir que ma ville n'a
pas pris l'eau entre guillemets lé pas
été touchés par son ami bon c'est là où
je travaille le plus quand même les
résultats sont partiels mais il sait
déjà qu'il ne remportera pas ce siège de
député que lui a ravie benoît hamon il
ya cinq ans jean michel fourgous adresse
alors un salut républicain à la gagnante
qu'il va croiser plutôt prévu nadia est
rejoint en effet la mairie d'elancourt
après s'être saluer avoir transmis
quelques conseils
c'est l'occasion aussi pour les deux
adversaires de quelques mises au point
après des échanges tendus pendant la
campagne les déclare actif c'est bien le
livre mieux c'est
donc disons bien que les gens attendent
des résultats rapides
[Musique]
je me
oui que ça vaut un déficit une gagnante
nouvelle en politique qui après une
campagne de terrain a relayé le message
du président de la république voit ses
efforts récompensés
elle est élue avec 52,96 % des voix
contre 47 0 4%
pour jean michel fourgous un 2e tour
marqué par un record d'abstention 58,3 %
en forte augmentation par rapport au
premier tour
je suis effectivement extrêmement
satisfaite des du résultat après après
-selon semaine de travail
ces longues semaines ou tous suis allé à
la rencontre de nous de nos concitoyens
et c'est aussi une grande fierté
aujourd'hui pour moi d'en arriver là
effectivement il ya quelques mois
j'étais cadre dans une banque
aujourd'hui je suis député à l'assemblée
nationale auprès du président emmanuel
macron donc pour moi c'est d'autant plus
une immense fierté de porter un projet
un projet comme celui là qui est de
celui de celui de la république en
marche à seulement 30 septembre cette
femme active cadre à paris est
originaire de trappes devient la 11e
députés en marche des yvelines ces
priorités d'élus la moralisation de la
vie politique et la réforme du code de
travail qu emmanuel macron compte mettre
en oeuvre dès cet été
elle va mettre en place une permanence
dans sa circonscription et a lancé une
plateforme collaborative pour donner la
parole aux habitants de la 11e
circonscription
[Applaudissements]
après une soirée où elle retrouve sa
famille ses amis ses soutiens et les
marcheurs elle salue tous ceux qui l'ont
accompagné durant cette campagne
il est épris de votre temps
ce n'est le temps professionnel à temps
familial parfois effectivement c'est
compliqué je ferai
mais vous l'avez fait et je vous
remercierai jamais assez pour ce que
vous avez fait et oui nous l'avons fait
nous avons battu venoix avant nous avons
ainsi une richesse forgo elle sait
qu'elle va devoir s'installer vite pour
travailler dans ces bureaux de
l'assemblée est lui partira d'ailleurs
pour une visite dès demain matin avant
une session de formation pour les
nouveaux arrivants et la journée
d'ouverture de la prochaine législature
avec l'ensemble des députés prévu le 27
juin
nous poursuivrons ce tour des résultats
dans les différentes circonscriptions
dans la 12ème également la république en
marche est arrivé en tête florence
granger élue députée elle rafle le siège
aux républicains à david douillet à
camille et oui on va le voir sur cette
infographie 56 63 % des suffrages
exprimés en faveur de florence grange eu
43 points 37% pour l'ancien député
sortant david douillet alors c'est son
expression qui a été reprise plusieurs
fois mais on peut le dire il a été mis
au tapis
l'ex judoka est battu dans cette
circonscription traditionnellement
ancrée à droite il avait pourtant reçu
le soutien de nombreux élus locaux
notamment le maire de poissy karl olive
mais cela n'a pas suffit visiblement à
arrêter la vague du parti des manuels
macro florence grange du député comme
beaucoup de candidats de la république
en marche elle aussi se revendiquer de
la société civile alors pour la
présenter un petit peu elle a 55 ans
elle est chargée de mission à la
direction générale de pôle emploi
elle n'avait pas de mandat jusqu'à
présent c'était sa première élection
elle a été directrice de l'anpe de
plaisir et donc vous l'aurez compris le
domaine qu'elle maîtrise le plus c'est
bien celui de l'emploi des premiers pas
en politique motivée par le discours d'
emmanuel macron un discours qui voulait
rassembler et c'est justement ce qui est
ressorti lors des remerciements de
florence granger après l annonce des
résultats à poissy on l'écouté j'ai à
coeur de travailler avec
citoyenne avec tous les sites web
avec l'ensemble des acteurs locaux des
acteurs économiques mais également des
élus
je pense qu'on ne peut faire un bon
travail que lorsque tous ensemble on a
dans la même direction
lorsque je vois le taux d'abstention
dans notre pays aujourd'hui aux
élections législatives
comme tout citoyen et comme tout citoyen
je m'interroge et l'abstention là aussi
a été élevé une fois de plus un électeur
sur deux ne s'est pas déplacé et oui
seulement 45,68 % de votants pour ce
deuxième tour
ces sept points de moins qu'au premier
plus de 52 % des inscrits s'étaient
mobilisés dimanche dernier et florence
grands justes souhaite retrouver la
confiance des électeurs
on a essayé de mobiliser au maximum les
électrices et les électeurs pour le
deuxième tour
mais le taux d'abstention également
était très fort et nous le regrettons et
nous aurons à coeur de ramener les
françaises et les français vers je
dirais les urnes et
j'espère qu'ils auront davantage
confiance dans les nouveaux visages dans
les pratiques qui seront renouvelées et
qu il
re qu'ils retourneront vers vers les
urnes je pense que c'est vraiment un
chantier sur les cales lequel pardon on
doit vraiment s'attaquer et ce matin la
candidate élue s'est rendu à la
direction générale de pôle emploi pour
demander à quitter son poste et pouvoir
ce qu'on sait pouvoir se consacrer
pleinement à ses nouvelles fonctions de
député député des yvelines député de la
12e mais du côté des républicains david
douillet lui n'a pas souhaité prendre la
parole tout à fait alors déjà hier soir
il n'était pas présent à poissy 1 pour
l' annonce des résultats nous avons
contacté ce matin sa suppléante qui a
indiqué que ni david douillet nid elle
ne souhaitaient s'exprimer pour
reprendre ses mots
l'élection est terminée maintenant il
faut passer à autre chose alors ce qu'on
s'est quand même c'est que david
douillet a reconnu très vite un dans la
soirée saadé fait même un peu avant
l'annoncé des résultats officiels il a
échangé avec florence granger et sur sa
page facebook
il a publié un message à l'attention de
la nouvelle députée et de ses soutiens
j'ai appelé florence granger pour lui
adresser mes chaleureuses félicitations
suite à son élection comme député de la
12e circonscription des yvelines
je lui souhaite beaucoup de réussite
dans ce mandat exigeant car seule la
réussite notre pays doit compter
désormais merci qu'amélie pour cependant
la 12e circonscription merci nicolas
également et merci à mélanie et aux
différents journalistes de la rédaction
qui ont travaillé pour cette édition
spéciale
on revoit les visages des députés de vos
nouveaux députés dans le sud des
yvelines
si un nouveau visage feu six nouvelles
personnes qui font leur entrée au sein
de l assemblée nous les suivrons tout au
long de ces cinq ans bien évidemment
journal le journal lui revient demain à
partir de est 18h à très bientôt
[Musique]